i don't know basically i have no idea
there you go
how can you how can you predict that i
mean you'd have to be
nostradamus mark two to get that one
right i mean uh d3 a really strange move
so he's played he's open with c3 now d3
but when you're playing the world
champion when you know that he's kind of
freestyling when he's uh kind of
just uh throwing these weird wacky ideas
against you it is hard and okay we've
transposed into a sicilian and you're
happy that simon i'm happy about this
because it's a chessable course um
is it yes it is brilliant i love it uh
richard is a very strong uh
international master brilliant player
and a brilliant theoretician but this is
this was called the british grand prix
because a lot of british players were
playing this particular setup that white
goes for and um
it's
getting out of theory so it's doing the
kind of thing that i think magnus
likes doing you're not into any real
deep theory and you can get often very
good attacking chances luke machine won
a fantastic game in this um against
chaparrinov going back to i think 2009
2009
it was in the european team
championships and it was kind of a kind
of a group
as well and uh yeah then basically luke
won this incredible game in 20 moves of
it so uh i i'm obviously excited to see
it because it was one of the most recent
courses that i made and it's an opening
i've played
quite a lot myself as well yeah the
whole idea is that if black does attack
at some point he comes
yeah exactly if black does castle sorry
then you can attack him you throw pawns
forward you bring your bishop out and
i mean you're basically a fortune teller
simon because the white queen has indeed
slid across one square she's heading for
this square now the h4 is exciting about
it you know the queen slides out
in the current position it's magnus to
play
okay he brings his knight out first
slightly surprising he didn't rush to
bring his queen into the attack this one
logical as well the white knight on the
decent square uh more centralized and
that's an interesting question because
he is i would say a very mature player
as in he doesn't normally like throwing
all his eggs into one basket he's not an
all-in player by any means when he plays
so
i don't know if he's going to throw
everything towards the black king and
you can see here the maneuver that he's
done is another very normal maneuver is
trying to make some exchanges of those
dangerous pieces and then start the
queen side play this move here just
moving the bishop once it's very slow
move that one would he even play a pawn
sack fight here it comes here it comes
so it's coming
and
yeah i can tell you that white has an
incredible score here you know it just
looks so dangerous so surprisingly it
isn't isn't any surprise um okay
meanwhile the black bishop has jumped
out but that's the second time in a row
that that black bishop has just moved
surprising a lot of time for vidic it
shows that he's clearly uncomfortable
with the kind of incoming attack if you
take with your bishop i guess the
downside is that this pawn might drop
off um you no longer protect this pawn
and your rook is under fire if pieces
come off the board but secondly the
black bishop can restore the balance
white knight back on its starting square
in a lot of structures and there you can
see
yeah and vid it here now creating
counter play on the c file and i i would
actually say that that has probably done
a good job here of uh
stopping any dangerous attack at least
magnus is the one retreating that's not
a good sign for the world champion
suddenly things are turning in black's
favor and
i think you're right simon he should
have bought your chestable course he
should have been watching because this
white knight is in the way still a very
rich position in store and okay in the
current position um he didn't take off
white tonight i'm slightly surprised he
brought his queen out instead and uh for
example after a trade here black
actually wins the white queen due to a
pin so white still has to be very
careful don't be greedy don't be hasty
magnus just uh forcing actually this
trade bishop for night and uh you all at
home are giving us creative answers and
uh bishop takes knight on the board
throws all the punches in the first
round i.e the opening but they're not
improving they're all around they're all
around like 2100 you might lose a lot of
games but you just got to try to do
something different just look for
players look for top players who have
your style choose openings that kind of
complement that but uh yeah if you're
playing for enjoyment just want to
attack want to change things up for the
sake of changing things up then um yeah
for black to do anything i know white
doesn't have great development well oh
he's gone the other way
to say this because i was 100 sure it
wasn't even a question my mind that
magnus would push this pawn it's just a
magnus move he does this all the time
and he loves his rook lifts it's boxed
in it's stuck it's got nowhere to go
suddenly push a pawn um sorry push this
pawn forward black blocks and lifting
the rook up suddenly the rook has an
easy path to an outpost actually if it
gets to this b5 square then it's going
to be a glorious piece so did it try to
stop that but
now the black knight is getting in the
way if anything can the black knight
maybe
re-root itself okay he's gone for the
more um
full frontal attack there yeah and uh
simon you mentioned black's plans i was
about to suggest this one black's queen
slides across one square
i think the simple plan is to get greedy
go and grab a pawn black's knight and
queen both looking at white's a pawn i'm
not really sure that's a relevant pawn
it costs black a lot of time to go and
take it but black's knight if it does
capture the white pawn on a4 then it
does get offside as we mentioned eyeing
up this pawn and magnus moves his bishop
if he defended this pawn i think a big
mistake not just uh strategically here
blocking in his own rook but tactically
because suddenly which pieces are
undefended for white this one and how
many pieces are lined up against it it's
quite a lot so black could actually play
knight takes pawn attacking the queen
and if the pawn recaptures then this
bishop at the bottom of the board falls
i don't know just uh to show the white
pawn steps forward if black can
eliminate this defender this defender
actually holds together all of white's
pawns really interesting move there from
magnus because we talked about on
passant earlier today
sometimes uh
me i know a lot of players as well we
just forget about moves if they allow on
person and this one wasn't even on my
radar i've got to admit
i've got to say this pawn push allowing
black to play on passant
the whole idea is that white's bishop at
the bottom of the board the white light
squared bishop on d1 is attacking
black's knight now and i was about to
say if he jumps forward with his knight
taking the spawn then there's a risk
this knight gets trapped behind enemy
lines white's bishop now under fire is
about to move i'm not sure exactly where
but uh next turn white will try and trap
this knight
um the knight black can give up at night
for a bunch of pawns but instead magnus
has gone in an opposite direction he
brought his bishop this way and actually
uh indirectly trying to attack the queen
so for example now if black does try and
evacuate the knight from uh from no
man's land then suddenly white's pawn
will step forward this is an attack
against the queen and wow it's really
livening up now
black is throwing everything at white's
pawn chain
trying to trade off pawns here but again
question is what happens if white pushes
forward maybe with his pawn in the
center attacking the queen and only five
minutes to choose
not easy
okay he does take this pawn double
attack
remember attacking this knight and
attacking the rook with your bishop
there's always going to be ideas of
opening up this discovered attack
against the queen and vivid decides it's
desperate times desperate measures are
called for and um just to go back a
couple of moves here after the white
bishop uh left forward black's knight
under attack we've been highlighting it
a few times so it gave itself up so
magnus has this
so he's wow he's gone for a while he's
gone for a
really crazy move there oh how is this
on his radar this is why the top players
are so good um because we were all
looking at this rook or maybe uh running
away from the attack white's rook under
fire but magnus has ignored both of
those ideas and pushed forward i mean so
much to calculate we have the drunken
pawns the three pawns in the middle of
the board and not just that we have a
double agent white pawn taking a bishop
magnus
okay taking this pawn surprising but
very surprising because now you can go
queen takes pawn track maybe it's just
too hot at his place because i'm looking
at
here we see a v that has 29 degrees at
home but
magnus has 25 degrees with the earthings
i think they're blowing off some steam
right now
definitely and we do know that magnus
likes his room's very very warm when he
plays often 25 26 degrees and okay the
current position it has finally become
less wild it's clarified a bit white has
an extra bishop but black has two pawns
in return yeah
so for example if white's bishop which
doesn't look great right now if it does
re-root um we could see that happen
right now magnus retreating the white
bishop and black's two pawns
okay this exact maneuver has happened on
the board um also very logical the uh
yeah the black pawns are just targets if
anything
he's gonna he can swap queens at any
moment uh i'd i would afford magnus just
going into an ending where he'll be a
piece up as well and well vidit's gonna
have to do an amazing defensive job here
to to hold uh this this position yeah
against that pawn that he's attacking
with a bishop um i i don't think he he
needs to worry about that i mean let's
say you you move the rook attack the
pawn swap the queens off it's got to be
winning short yeah swapping the queens
off i don't think is that so i'm just
going to move my bishop back and attack
that weakness of my rook i mean it's
really delicate
and nice nice maneuvering there okay all
right okay first he's attacking the
black f7 pawn black king black has to
defend that with his rook i think at
some point it's going to become a real
problem i mean maybe not now because
it's not so complicated but at some
point things always get complicated and
that's when you need to have that extra
time uh there will be a moment where
magnus sets a trap or kind of forces
vivid to calculate and having less than
a minute trying to work out magnus's
plan though
maybe he's just doing a little bit of
maneuvering around for the time being
until until he works out the way to to
go forward
but i i always enjoy a good battle here
i'm hoping for a good finish where vita
can actually put up some counter play
and we could have an enjoyable
late game that was a really boring
answer wasn't it i was gonna give a
similarly boring answer
you stole the words out of my mouth so
it's
uh okay we're coming up to the seventh
rank okay i think this one's going to be
winning for magnus sooner or later but i
was going to say i think it's going to
be quite a long game still so how many
moves
i'm going to say 100 just because i'm a
scientist
but it's 38 moves already it feels like
they've played like 50 moves but they
haven't eight okay i'll go 80. i'll go
yeah i'll be a long one
it's definitely going to depend upon
vedic because we know that magnus is not
going to stop pushing here regardless so
it's uh so what moves have we got okay
so we've got 180
i'm going to say lower than that
actually i'm going to say oh especially
after this last minute after this last
movie oh you're getting more information
every move it changes quite a bit you
declared your intentions too come on
hurry up get you moving
let's see how big it responds um no you
can't just drag it out you've got to
decide yeah okay
70. okay the the black pieces would be
able to fight off the white army for a
long time with those two extra pawns but
suddenly white is about to win one of
those pawns they're not playing matches
here but he's wondered against one of
the guys on top david untold just what
you needed and there can be enough to
kind of launch a few other victories
and i did also see some stats by ty our
numbers guy um just before today and
david anton had 96 percent chance of
qualifying for the knockouts so yeah uh
we're celebrating going but yeah yeah
sure david antony has had a great
tournament i'm sure he'll
still do well but i heard you say
yesterday simon that once kuwaine wins a
game here he's gonna he's gonna roll
he's gonna get into rhythm he can just
lift him to calculate better so yeah so
we might see
i hope many more wins from gwen in the
next rounds it is a really good cause i
mean i know i know i have to really say
that i can't say it's rubbish but it is
actually it's intense so they're all
great but gwen's course is is special oh
for grabs you need to defend that born
nope you can't do that
so he's lost to pawn and the queens have
come off now it's four versus three on
one side of the board this one is
winning for white still if all the pawns
disappear then brooklyn bishop versus
rook is technically a draw look out look
how happy magnus is he's got that big
smile on his face he's clearly
clearly very excited about how the
game's going here so uh
i mean
it's a good picture is that you know
i mean being surrounded by this great
british humor is one of the best places
i could have been right now
i love that comment simon
who is made me laugh
um okay so what is the winning plan for
white and how long will it take because
we're closing out of move 61.
this type of idea for example in a
situation like this he can always bring
his rook back and stop the white bishop
from infiltrating he's gone for the f5
man they've gone for a pawn push wow
okay really interesting by magnus
instead of going the long way round with
the bishop which i was hoping for to get
to move 100
he's pushed this pawn forward it's
edible in two different ways if you take
this way as black your pawn in the
corner drops suddenly white gets harry
the h1 another theme of the day uh and
yeah suddenly you're breaking through to
this weakness as well it could be 61. it
could be you know it's sort of a
that h pawn is going to surely just win
the day now i mean uh i
yeah black has to huddle up no
not
does this one work
he wants to trade a set of pawns but it
looks like the white rook can go up to
the seventh rank with a check maybe i
mean can you just is that a winning rook
and pawn ending even often you can often
you can give up material to to get into
an ending that you know is winning and
it looks very close to being winning
with the white king which is very close
to winning but
i'm not sure if it's this is if this
wins you play it so this is why magnus
maybe black and hold by the king going
back and just blocking this square just
uh maybe yeah maybe just in time but
you're right simon this is exactly what
what magnus is calculating right now
magnus would love to just take this pawn
create a pass pawn of his own but maybe
he's not in time maybe he needs to save
his bishop first and there we go he does
save his bishop at least now black gets
this kind of cluster of pawns um these
three yes some of them will drop after
white's last move
dropping the rook back pinning and
winning this pawn but
if now vidic can trade off the rook
somehow it's a distant dream but if he
can kind of make the rooks disappear
from the board even if he loses these
three pawns if you're all the
highlighted pieces now if they all drop
off the board it's actually a draw
because uh a white bishop on light
squares alone and a pawn that promotes
on dark squares cannot win black's king
will just go and hide in the corner and
there's no way to evict it so some hope
for vidic yeah maybe and i just had to
be so careful even without these two
pawns it's not easy right not an easy
not an easy win
maybe the pawns kind of help white in
some ways you often get that these
endings that
black wants to keep checking the white
king but sometimes the pawns get in the
way so you know off checks towards the
white king which you could see
potentially uh potentially here
in some in some cases for example now i
think a simple winning plan for white is
just bringing the bishop forward pushing
this pawn at the right time and
there we go magnus is about to maybe win
one pawn and then push his own pawn
simultaneously it looks like he's
getting closer and uh there we go we're
gonna get the exact same game you've
mentioned there ivanka all of the black
pawns are about to drop off if we rush
forward to the current position who's 63
so it's get closing in on 71 yeah but um
i was 70 right 70 60 so 61 has gone yeah
61 is gone and the thing is that people
were waiting for me as well and they
were like yeah she's gonna win yeah he's
uh he's still playing still playing okay
right oh really 10 cent game there
against prague maybe fizzling out to a
draw
meanwhile magnus he's forced the black
king out of the corner that's the first
step
now the black king not blockading in the
dark square in the corner but the
problem is you can't give up your black
rook and uh i mean you can't force white
to take your black work and i think
we're about to see vidic has he just
resigned he has done 68 move 68 well
done